d'où la victoire française aujourd'hui
en rugby le quinze de france qui a battu
l'ecosse remporte le tournoi des cinq
nations et en cyclisme laurent fignon
remporte la première grande classique de
l'année
milan san remo corps seul il immobilisé
après les fonctionnaires transports
commerces pêcheurs à leur tour en grève
halte à la discrimination
professionnelle et au harcèlement sexuel
des femmes un congrès réuni à paris
lance un appel aux gouvernements de la
communauté européenne dans ce journal
une enquête travers la france qui nous
montre que ces problèmes sont loin
d'être résolus madame monsieur bonsoir
que vous soyez sportif ou non il ya des
soirs où les victoires françaises
doivent être fêté dignement
c'est le cas ce soir avec le cyclisme et
le rugby d'abord le rugby les français
vainqueurs des écossais cet après midi
au parc des princes 19 à 3 remporte le
tournoi des cinq nations 89
sous les yeux de la princesse anne
d'angleterre qui avait fait tout
spécialement le voyage francis maroteaux
princesse anne que voyez-vous venir
français qu'aux parcs tout simplement et
jamais une victoire et que c'est sur
cette pelouse des princes alors
tradition respectée berbizier s'arrache
de sa mêlée feinte la passe mais passe
le mur écossais pierre berbizier
mystifie toute la défense écossaise pour
aplatir le premier essai français
6 3 pour la france bureaux ayant
transformé et puis voici venir monsieur
plus
monsieur serge blanco qui passe la
surmultipliée dépasse les échos cet
essai de blanco deuxième essai français
serge blanco plus vite serge blanco plus
fort blancou plus haut alors blanco
c'est mieux serge is magic
et la fête continue deuxième mi-temps
troisième essai tricolore avec la hargne
de philippe sella
c'est là qu'ils s'engagent qui dégage la
balle pour andrieu andrieu lagisquet la
france gagne 19 3 c'est l'agenais pour
le nîmois andrieu le nîmois pour le
basque et lagisquet qui aplatit le
troisième essai français
mais la france remporte le tournoi grâce
surtout aux gallois en rouge jones pour
son ouvreur torner chandelle underwood
allait contrôler la balle mais web
l'arrière lui tricote alors que les
centre gallois s'enfonce dans la défense
anglaise
hall le trois-quarts est le plus prompt
de galles l'emportent 12,9 et permet à
la france de remporter ce tournoi 89/100
la princesse anne d'angleterre laurent
fignon lui leur revenant champion
cycliste français qui avait fait une
mauvaise saison l'année dernière démarre
en trombe avec une magnifique victoire
dans la classique cycliste milan san
remo qu'il avait d'ailleurs déjà
remporté en 88 mais la suite n'avait pas
été à la hauteur francis maroteaux milan
san remo peut-il sourire deux années de
suite un français questions-réponses
s'il s'agit de laurent fignon peut-être
le double vainqueur du tour remporte
pour la deuxième année consécutive la
prime avait là la course du printemps
mais ils gagnent autant avec ses jambes
qu'avec sa tête la preuve au micro de
patrick chêne j'ai accéléré beaucoup de
parakou cette époque pour le tester et
puis le dernier coup quand j'ai attaqué
vraiment puis que j'ai continué généreux
sur ma lancée
mais là j'ai vu qu'il était un peu juste
et j'ai relancé encore et je suis parti
tout seul c'est pas facile j'étais pas
sûr de mon coup mais bon votre marché
mais de qui parle laurent fignon de
frank may assène un néerlandais de 24
ans qui ne pourra pas suivre le rythme
du français fignon finalement vainqueur
pour la deuxième fois de suite en italie
c'est tout simplement fignon nisme
à 28 ans fignon remporte l'une de ses
plus belles victoires et en plus il
prend la tête de la toute nouvelle coupe
du monde de cyclisme par et ont
maintenant un instant l'actualité sur un
événement dont nous fêtons aujourd'hui
cette semaine le premier anniversaire il
y a un an tout juste pour la première
fois en europe une petite fille de six
de six jours pas plus victime d'une
malformation du coeur subissait une
greffe cardiaque
aujourd'hui lucie c'est son nom wynants
normalement ou presque au milieu de sa
famille reportage de delphine de la
selle et yanji qu'à celui ci à un an
c'est la première fois qu'elle voit
autant de gens par contre eux
la connaissent tous sa vie a commencé
dans cet hôpital à la naissance son
coeur défaillant l'a condamné à mort
pour la première fois en europe des
chirurgies allait tenter une greffe du
coeur sur un bébé de six jours pour
l'équipe qui l'a soigné cet anniversaire
est une véritable récompense
ça fait très plaisir surtout de l'avoir
en pleine santé comme ça bon moi je dis
c'est vraiment une réussite
la responsabilité d'une telle
intervention incombe aux parents et à
l'équipe chirurgicale mais il n'est
malheureusement pas toujours possible
d'opérer à temps c'est une course contre
la mort cas chez ces enfants très mal
formés à la naissance
le délai de survie est très court et
durant ce temps il est nécessaire de
trouver un greffon c'est à dire de
trouver un donneur
aujourd'hui lucie mène une vie à peu
près normale
bien sûr il ya les médicaments anti
rejet et les visites régulières à
l'hôpital mais son développement est
tout à fait encourageant pour un tel
résultat
les parents ont dû réaménager leur
emploi du temps laissant de côté leurs
amis leurs habitudes leur métier j'ai
une activité de création et étant donné
qu'elle ne peut pas aller en crèche je
suis donc à l'appartement avec elle et
pour l'instant je n'ai pas encore bien
réussi à reprendre un rythme de travail
régulier et on n'avait pas mesuré la
fatigue que ça supposerait on n'avait
pas mesuré la
l'enl angoisse qu'on avait
quotidiennement est ce qu'elle allait
bien prendre ces médicaments est ce
qu'elle allait bien dormir bien manger
est ce que nous on n'allait pas lui
amener un virus malin etc
et c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un peu le
vide autour de nous jusqu'à présent
l'uci a vécu dans un univers extrêmement
protégé archi propre sans véritable
contact avec l'extérieur
dans quelques années il lui faudra
affronter l'école la rue et les autres
bref l'espoir d'une vie à peu près
normale
la corse immobilisé la grève des
fonctionnaires se poursuit et il faut y
ajouter aujourd'hui les transports
maritimes aériens petit à petit tous les
secteurs économiques de l'île cessent le
travail aujourd'hui
les marins pêcheurs sur place le
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
françoise joly et dominique merde le
santa regina est arrivé ce matin du
continent il est ancré au large car
impossible de rentrer dans le port
depuis trois jours les pêcheurs en
bloquent l'accès eux ne sont pas
fonctionnaires mais soutiennent les
grévistes
et puis ils veulent que l'on parle de
leurs problèmes leur cheval de bataille
sauvez la petite pêche menacé par le
grand marché européen de 92
tous les ports de corse était paralysée
aujourd'hui occupé également par les
grévistes de la fonction publique comme
ses employés communaux de bastia non
syndiqués et décidés à se faire entendre
nous sommes ici pour défendre nos droits
et pour être ici donc jusqu'à canadien
justin bieber il y aura une autre
réunion pour une autre assemblée
générale de tous les tous les délégués
les responsables le personnel
et puis on verra il en attendant la
rencontre de lundi entre michel rocard
les élus corses
la grogne monte dans l'île notamment
celle des transporteurs routiers
aujourd'hui à bastia ils ont bloqué une
grande partie des accès de la ville
ils protestent contre le blocage du port
qui les empêche de travailler la route
sa présence est que nous avons les
bateaux qui sont cycliques et mouille au
large de bastia avec de la marchandise
qui est en train de périr à bord et puis
il y a les rues de bastia où les
poubelles ne sont plus ramassées depuis
trois jours les tas d'ordures se font de
plus en plus envahissants et pourtant
toujours pas de mouvement d'humeur de la
population il est vrai que ce week-end
de crise est aussi celui d'élections et
même de fait dans plusieurs villes de
corse on célèbre saint joseph à bastia
la miséricorde à ajaccio mais l'accord
se fixe maintenant son regard sur
matignon
car l'enjeu de la rencontre de lundi est
présent dans tous les esprits
conséquence de cet état de grève qui
aurait pu être dangereuse cet après midi
un avion charter du club de nouvelles
frontières s'est posé sur l'aéroport
d'ajaccio
sans mesures de sécurité puisque les
employés ont cessé le travail christophe
martel c'est vers 17 heures qu'un avion
charter un boeing 737 de la compagnie
corsair affrété par nouvelles frontières
demande à la tour de contrôle d'ajaccio
de se poser le personnel réquisitionné
prévient le commandant de bord que du
fait de la grève le service de sécurité
et la maintenance ne sont pas assurés le
commandant de bord prend alors la
responsabilité de se poser sans sécurité
selon les pompiers de l'aéroport l'avion
charter ramenait de paris
soixante neuf électeurs venus voter sur
l'île il n'y a pas eu d'incident les
soixante neuf passagers ont pu quitter
l'appareil mais celui-ci ne repartira
pas ainsi en ont décidé les grévistes à
lyon cet après midi une manifestation
contre
livre de salman rushdie les fameux
versets sataniques interdite par le
préfet de région qui craignaient que le
défilé ne dégénère avec des slogans
condamnant à mort l'écrivain britannique
comme ce fut le cas à paris il y a
quinze jours maintenant
même si en l'occurrence ce n'était pas
l'intention des organisateurs de lyon
nous envoyés spéciaux sur place bernard
pradines aux relents terre
les crs ont donc séparés sans aucun
incident quelques groupes
quelques dizaines de personnes
mobilisées aujourd'hui contre un livre
considéré comme une insulte à leur
communauté comme un mensonge qui
blessent toute croyance musulmane juive
ou chrétienne dont contient préciser
nous les musulmans du rhône qu'on a
organisé cette manifestation uniquement
dans le but d'interdire par les voies
légales
l'édition du gourmand blasphématoire de
salman rushdie leva cette année je tiens
à préciser que aucunement on a demandé
la tête de rochdi
ce n'est pas notre problème ici en tant
que musulman en france 2/france
musulmans français
l'esprit de la manif de lyon était
beaucoup moins violent qu'il ya quinze
jours à paris le préfet de police a
préféré ne prendre aucun risque
les jeunes musulmans vont demander une
nouvelle autorisation de manifester
cette semaine la presse internationale a
tristement commémorer le cinquième
anniversaire de la capture de l'otage
américain terry anderson qui demeure
avec plusieurs autres emprisonnés au
libre sans se montrer égoïste disons
simplement qu'il n'y a plus de français
parmi ces otages tous ont été libérés
leurs visages que notre journal celui
d'antenne 2 a diffusé pendant tout le
temps de leur captivité reste gravé dans
nos mémoires pourtant l'un au moins a
été oubliée ou plus exactement personne
n'en a jamais vraiment parlé pour toutes
sortes de raisons il était pourtant le
premier ses dettes en février 1984
christian joubert conducteur de travaux
était enlevé à beyrouth et détenu
pendant deux mois exactement
il a aujourd'hui 41 ans est depuis sa
libération sa vie n'est qu'une longue
suite d'ennuis
nos reporters thierry calmette noël
alexandre nous retrouver près d'orléans
où il vit aujourd'hui
christian joubert n'oublie pas mais la
musique le sport dans son association de
poires ligne bâton lui permettent à
peine peut surmonter son cauchemar
au liban dans libération hier par les
miliciens du mouvement chiite amal d'un
ingénieur libéré armes aux poings par
les milices chiites amal après 62 jours
de captivité et un souvenir dérisoire sa
tenue de prisonnier du dire a dit sami
la chose qu'ils vont laisser vos yeux
qu'avec sa libéré dans ce pyjama là je
vous avais été attaché tout le temps de
votre attention
pratiquement tout le temps j'avais
toujours les chaînes aux pieds ça
c'était en permanence tangente à une
libérer un bras trentaine d'ouvriers 2
ça dépend des fois j'ai toujours été
attaché dans son album de photos il
cherche encore pourquoi lui depuis deux
ans à beyrouth il s'occupait de chantier
d'école pour une entreprise d'orléans et
soudain le 15 février 84 à la sortie de
l'ambassade de france
deux hommes armés l'arête et l'enfant
dans une voiture s'ensuivent 62 jours de
captivité dans trois endroits différents
sévices brimades angoisse aujourd'hui
nous nous savons mais christian joubert
lui fut le premier otage français du
moment où j'ai été en permanence et de
vendée dont j'entendais c'est déclic
d'armé choses autour de moi alors est-ce
que c'était pour me faire peur vous
aviez peur ah oui et puis le silence de
tous côtés 55 jours après l'enlèvement
son entreprise apprend officiellement sa
disparition et le comble dix jours après
sa libération effective la famille
apprend à son tour que l'état va
s'occuper des recherches à beyrouth
pendant tout ce temps là madame joubert
devra se débrouiller seule avec ses deux
enfants complètement isolé j'ai
connaissiez le tout les deux jours après
pour les relancer les relancer mais
personnes s'est déplacée personnes après
stéphane traumat été
jamais vous voir ici personne même pas
un homme politique quoique ce soit
est-ce que vous avez été suivies par des
psychologues
vous avez été débriefée comme on dit non
je fais j'ai refusé sans pourquoi je
sais pas je préfère m en sortir tout
seul
est ce que vous sentez quelqu'un comme
tout le monde en ce moment
ballon donc on peut pas se sentir à
quelqu'un comme tout le monde parce
qu'on n'a pas envie qu'un événement qui
n'est pas ordinaire il quand je vois
après la suite qui a été fait en ce qui
concerne les autres otages
je considère que je ne suis pas comme
toujours bien les avec des problèmes
quotidiens d'abord le chômage son
entreprise déposé son bilan le jour de
sa disparition 6400 francs dette sociale
et d'assurance pour tout revenu mensuel
essien joubert un homme discret un sans
grade
accablé par la malchance un otage
oublier à l'étranger israël des morts
sur deux fronts aujourd'hui un soldat
israélien tué sur la frontière avec la
jordanie à la suite d'une attaque d'un
commando qui tentaient de pénétrer en
israël
et puis trois palestiniens tués à gaza
valérie fournier la nuit dernière une
embuscade a réveillé l'une des
frontières les plus sûres de l'état
hébreu ces soldats israéliens vient de
découvrir l'un de leurs compagnons tué
un autre blessé
à leurs côtés les traces de pas de deux
hommes venant de jordanie deux
agresseurs probablement palestiniens qui
auraient été arrêtés ce soir par les
jordaniens
c'est la première fois depuis décembre
87 qu'une tentative d'infiltration à
partir du territoire jordanien réussi
pour le gouvernement de jérusalem
si l'on en croit y rabin c'est à la
jordanie d'empêcher ce genre
d'incursions elle est considérée comme
responsable
à l'autre bout du pays sans qu'il ait
rapport de cause à effet le territoire
de gaza a connu une journée de violences
comme on en a pas vu depuis quatre mois
bilan depuis ce matin trois morts dans
les rangs palestiniens ainsi que 25
blessés touchés par les balles de
l'armée israélienne un bilan qui
pourrait devenir plus lourd
al'approche défaite qui commémore le
départ des juifs des germes un
prolongement de la trêve respecté par
les terroristes de letea basque depuis
deux mois et qui doit se terminer la
semaine prochaine c'est ce que réclamait
cet après-midi par milliers dans les
rues de bilbao des manifestants qui
espère ainsi faire avancer les
négociations entre le théâtre et le
gouvernement de madrid qui ont lieu
actuellement à alger en territoire
neutre
les manifestants de bilbao n'était ni
pour ni contre le théâtre gouvernement
espagnol ce qu'il réclamait 7
enfin la paix michel mompontet philippe
etcheverry
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues de bilbao
derrière une seule banderole
un seul slogan la paix maintenant et
pour toujours
répondant à l'appel de tous les partis
politiques tous sauf un
herri batasuna le parti proche de letea
ses basques ont parfois parcouru des
centaines de kilomètres de tous les
coins du pays pour venir demander à une
semaine de la fin de la trêve des
attentats que la violence ne reprennent
pas a alger les dirigeants espagnols et
ceux de l'hôtel on négocier durant un
mois pour tenter d'instaurer cette paix
cette paix que la rue réclame ici dans
la ville la plus farouchement
indépendantistes de tout le pays basque
le 26 mars la trêve de 60 jours qu'avait
instauré le thé à sera donc fini cette
trêve débouchera-t-elle sur une
véritable solution pacifique venus
d'alger c'est en tout cas le souhait
exprimé par ces manifestants la paix
n'avait jamais mobilisés ici autant de
monde à bilbao bilbao au coeur de la
violence depuis deux décennies
l'actualité politique française en
veilleuse aujourd'hui en attendant
demain le deuxième tour des élections
municipales tous les résultats
commentaires débat à partir de 19h50
demain soir sur antenne 2 de nouveau
mobilisés pour une opération spéciale
élections en participation avec europe 1
et paris match
jacques violet nous détaille maintenant
la logistique de cette soirée spéciale
dès 19h55 toujours plus et plus
rapidement les enjeux et les surprises
de ce
deuxième tour des municipales les
résultats les estimations dans les 172
ville reste est en ballottage des
reportages et des directs avec nos
équipes nos journalistes dans 18 villes
de province pour chaque ville
l'image de chaque mairie a été dessiné
toutes les différentes solutions ont été
mises en mémoire dans les ordinateurs
le portrait de chaque candidat a été
mémoriser pour qu'ils puissent
apparaître dès les résultats connus deux
grands débats en direct avec des
personnalités politiques
les analyses et les commentaires pour
chaque parti politique
le nombre de villes gagnées ou perdues
par rapport aux municipales de 83 enfin
notre opération minitel en composant le
36 15 suivi du code civique
vous obtiendrez directement le résultat
de votre ville pour ce deuxième tour
devant l'affluence de vos appels 435
milles dimanche dernier nous avons
doublé les possibilités d'accès dès
19h55
demain dimanche sur antenne 2 votre
soirée élections municipales les
américains renouent avec le succès dans
la conquête spatiale leur navette
discovery parti lundi est rentré tout
normalement cet après midi toutes les
missions techniques ont été réalisés de
plus les astronautes ont également
enregistré des signes très nets des
maladies de la terre pollution
déforestation et ses conséquences
érosion des sols et désertification
laurent bouvier c'était la troisième
mission américaine depuis la reprise des
vols de navette
en septembre dernier quatre jours 23h39
pratiquement sans histoire avec en prime
un atterrissage applaudi par les quatre
cent mille spectateurs venus accueillir
la navette sur la base d'edwards en
californie mission sans histoire mais
mission réussie puisque discovery et ses
5 astronautes ont déployé dans l'espace
un satellite de communication t drs
qui permettra avec deux autres
satellites du même type d'assurer des
communications quasi permanente entre la
terre et les véhicules spatiaux d'autres
expériences scientifiques ont eu lieu
pendant ce vol et l'atterrissage lui
même a été un exercice nouveau puisque
discovery était équipé d'un système de
freinage renforcé destiné à permettre
l'atterrissage de la navette à pleine
charge en cas de retour en catastrophe
sur terre au cours de la phase de
lancement pour le commandant de bord
michael côte tout s'est bien passé et
six autres vols de navette devrait avoir
lieu cette année
conséquence du tremblement de terre du
mois de décembre les autorités
soviétiques ont décidé de fermer une
centrale nucléaire installée en arménie
et qui heureusement n'avait pas été
touchées par la catastrophe
en congrès européen vient de se tenir à
paris organisé par l'association contre
les violences faites aux femmes au
travail les congressistes ont adopté une
charte demande en eau douce gouvernement
de la communauté européenne une
meilleure protection des femmes contre
les discriminations professionnelles et
le harcèlement sexuel un sujet qui fait
encore sourire certains ils ont tort
les exemples que nos envoyés spéciaux
dominique pradalié jean-françois chevet
ont recueilli dans toute la france
montre qu'en 1989 malgré les progrès
réalisés
le problème reste posé dans toute sa
médiocrité de la part des hommes qui se
rendent coupables de tels actes
mais j'ai été licencié parce que je suis
une femme au poste que je tenais ils ont
décidé par une note de service que les
femmes ne vais plus travailler dans les
dans l'est des fois c'est à dire que
dans un service technique alors que ce
poste n'est pas supprimer ce poste a été
repris par une part à monsieur donc ce
poste n'a pas été supprimée travailler
dans une très bonne ambiance avec une
équipe une équipe avec laquelle je
m'entendais très bien pour un travail
était passionnant je trouve ça très très
tristes qu'à notre époque on sera obligé
de se battre
d'une façon intensive justement pour eux
essayez de
de conserver notre notre notre statut de
femmes dans les entreprises
tout ça en 89 jeanne demande
l'annulation du licenciement économique
et porte plainte contre la note de
service sexistes et illégale j'annonce
que je vais être maman que j'attends des
jumeaux dont je suis très enthousiaste
pour leur expliquer tout je m'aperçois
que les visages autour de moi se ferme
le président devient un fou furieux me
dit qu'il se fout des sumos qui se fout
du code du travail qui se fout des
conventions collectives
je suis mise à pied immédiatement
impossible de retourner à mon bureau je
tente de revenir quand même je suis
arrêté par les vigiles
je suis brutalisé maltraités je reçoit
ensuite une infinité de licenciement à
la suite de cette quand je reçois cette
lettre j'ai failli faire un avortement
j'ai été alité pendant trois semaines
donc ce n'est pas touché d'argent depuis
le 31 décembre
je n'ai aucune feuille de paye je n'ai
pas de papiers je ne peux pas m'inscrire
au chômage je n'ai pas trouvé de travail
frédéric portes planes pour licenciement
abusif et demande des dommages et
intérêts j'ai été licencié après avoir
subi pendant des années les tracasseries
disons d'un chef de service qui avait
vraiment des abus de pouvoir caractérisé
en 84 on a fait un montage
pornographiques avec une de mes photos
le responsable n'a pas été sanctionné et
comme je me suis plainte c'est moi qui a
été mise au placard isolé et son travail
pendant un an
ensuite on a voulu me rétrograde et j'ai
refusé alors on m'a licencié en mars 86
faut pas rester vraiment en se disant je
dois tout accepter c'est pas possible
parce que de toute façon c'est pas une
solution et le chef de service ou le
responsable on profite de plus en plus
c'est pour ça que vous témoignez à que
je peux témoigner parce que je sais
qu'il y en a d'autres qui est vraiment
en risque même leur santé juste à leur
vie pour garder un travail étant donné
la crise actuelle
luce a gagné son procès n'étant pas
responsable des grossièretés et brimades
de ses collègues elle ne devait pas être
licencié il me disait quand el haddad
intérêt que tu es clitoridienne vaginale
situ
je finis par te laisses tézier il
n'arrêtait pas de d'essayer de me
toucher toute la journée je me dis que
je ne cèderai jamais et à compter de ce
moment là il a fait basculer ses
propositions sur des brimades
professionnel avec manipulation par
d'autres personnes et sur des reproches
sur le travail qui avait effectué
plusieurs mois auparavant
rien n'allait plus du jour au lendemain
rien n'allait ni dans le travail ni dans
les relations avec les autres personnes
rien n'allait plus j'étais licencié sur
le champ sans rien gaël avec
l'association contre les violences
faites aux femmes au travail portent
plainte pour licenciement abusif
on est dirigé par des hommes que des
hommes et pas c'est eux qui nous disent
quand on doit aller aux toilettes quand
on doit quitter notre qu est ce qu on
doit aller manger etc
il ya une différence entre les salaires
d'hommes et de femmes au même niveau une
femme qui rendent comme tessières même
si les vingt ans dans l'entreprise
pendant un temps à traquer tire à moins
que pendant un certain moment à l'oeil
un peu la cote avec hf donc là on lui de
fournir un petit travail peinard mais
malheureusement ça dure
il faut savoir aussi que chez nous au
delà de trente deux ans nous sommes des
vieilles donc on essaye de le foot au
placard au mois de septembre on a fait
une grève parce qu'il ya des
licenciements abusifs
rêvons un peu je crois que c'est
nécessaire après un tel reportage
revenus rêvons un peu avec la sortie du
guide michelin 1989 la bible des
gastronomes discrétion efficacité
ces jugements sont rarement démentie le
guide sorti pour la première fois
gratuitement en 1900 à 35 mille
exemplaires il est aujourd'hui vendu à
720 mille exemplaires pour le premier
tirage cette année une seule troisième
étoiles le maximum en europe pour le
restaurant le crocodile à strasbourg
propriétaire est cuisinier et millions
rouge est très connu le guide
il figurait en bonne place c'est-à-dire
par des des toilettes une consécration
leur nombre est sévèrement contrôlé même
s'il n'y a pas de quotas les loups la
cuisse ça vous paraît un bon film mais
chine bon je crois que c'est un peu une
caricature inspecteurs michelin anonymes
qui doit rester comme disait de gaulle
c'est toujours tout à fait étonnant
beaucoup convenablement chaussée
solitaire vous accompagnez les
inspecteurs prospects pour une seule
règle la discrétion chez leur employeur
on a refusé de nous dire leur nombre
mais on nous a affirmé que ce sont des
hommes pour la plupart et qu'ils ont
fait l'école hôtelière même si l'un
d'entre eux vient d'une école de
commerce l'essec une autre ici à
strasbourg l'un de ses inspecteurs
caricaturé par louis de funès est passé
grâce à lui et à d'autres le chef a
obtenu sa troisième étoile récompense
ultime pour un homme qui pense qu'on
employant plus de trois ingrédients dans
un plat on en perles vous car ici la vie
d'un plat est tissée au fil d'or depuis
qu'on l'a annoncé en cuisine le bras est
un outil mais il dépasse
il transcende un savoir faire il
respecte l'esprit de la cuisine
il ne fait que souligner le goût de ce
centre un poisson que n'a semble-t-il
pas manger l'inspecteur
tiens monsieur qui est venu qui a mangé
un couteau de truffes l'année dernière
il était souriant affable
je soupçonne que c'était un inspecteur
du chemin mais il est venu est parti
sans se faire connaître c'est la série
était de votre troisième frère je ne
sais pas ces mystères à la table du
prince du luxembourg on accueille avec
les égards dus à son rang 1 mais de
qualité et si des esprits chagrins
venait à trouver qu'il y a quelque chose
d'injuste à faire une cuisine
inaccessible à la plupart d'entre nous
il aurait raison ils peuvent aussi
regretter de ne pouvoir s'offrir la
joconde pour leur salle à manger aux
l'homme
oui voilà et pour le pousse café
maintenant la magnifique exhibition de
la nouvelle championne du monde de
patinage artistique couronner cet après
midi à paris elle est ni elle n'est ni
américaine ni soviétique
c'est la première victoire d'une
japonaise midori ito regarder
et pour terminer le printemps quelques
semaines avant l'heure au zoo de
rotterdam en hollande d'une maman ours a
mis au monde un bébé qui effectue sa
première sortie sous l'oeil attendri de
philippe gassot regarder il était une
fois un petit ourson qui n'avait pas de
nom né il y a trois mois on ne savait
toujours pas si c'était une fille ou si
c'était un garçon peu importe quand
arrive le printemps c'est le moment de
faire ses premiers pas il faut savoir
que tout autour de moi même si vous ne
les voyez pas il y à beaucoup de monde
beaucoup c'est ça les stars au début on
suit sa mère sarah sur ne souriait pas
vous feriez comme moi mais quand elle
part qu'elle voulait seul c'est là que
les choses se compliquent
je ne vais pas tarder à y aller mais
elle est quand même pas chaude
en fait c'est pas maintenant je voulais
y aller mais je n'ai pas vu la marche
mines ma mère n'est pas loin et
heureusement à trois mois c'est vrai on
a le derrière lourd c'est ça
l'apprentissage
un petit coup de main et on est sorties
d'affaires
c'est pas parce que c'est ma mère mais
je peux vous dire qu'elle est quand même
très fier de moi c'est mignon quand ces
petits voilà pas de nouveau nés cet
après midi à l'arrivée du tiercé vous
allez comprendre pourquoi il y avait que
des favoris le 13 le 8 et le 2 ça
rapporte 1825 francs pour ce qui
concerne le quarté + vous ajoutez le 5
et vous gagnez un petit peu plus de 8000
francs
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo avec
josé blanc lapierre le dernier journal
c'est philippe gassot kivu le présentera
tout à l'heure après un champs elysées
présenté ce soir comme c'est l'habitude
par michel drucker spéciale cinéma on
peut dire ce soir avec notamment
d'austin hoffman isabelle adjani daniel
auteuil je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne je vous dis à
demain 13h et je vous signale tout de
suite que notre journal de demain soir
est avancé en raison des élections
municipales il aura lieu à 19h 20
précise bonsoir à tous
elle